the city hall in almaty charred and
still smoldering the presidential palace
was set on fire too
burnt out vehicles littering the streets
of kazakhstan's commercial capital where
these protests have been their most
violent
the authorities have characterized the
unrest as being led by foreign trained
terrorist groups releasing video like
this of cars filled with weapons as
proof
and horrific images that we've blurred
of decapitated bodies they say 18
security officers have been killed and
dozens of protesters in their words
eliminated with more than 2 000 detained
the first contingents of russian
paratroopers have arrived in country to
try and restore order after president
takayev asked for help from the csto a
military defensive alliance of ex-soviet
states
it's supposed to be a short-term
deployment it may not stay that way the
csto is a russian
um led organization which they see as
their nato for the eurasian region and
kazakhstan has been a member of that
since 2003 but one of his greatest
achievements the former president was to
kind of keep russia at bay the eu has
urged russia to respect kazakhstan's
sovereignty the foreign secretary too
condemning the violence our thoughts are
with those who have lost their lives
in what has happened and we condemn the
acts of violence and destruction of
property in our marty and we will be uh
coordinating further uh with our allies
on what further steps we should take
these protests have spread across the
country at lightning speed morphing into
a more general discontent over living
standards and stagnant one-party rule
russia may be stepping in to help but
this is also vladimir putin's worst
nightmare happening next door a reminder
of how quickly the cracks can start to
appear in authoritarian rule
diana magnes sky news moscow